[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce numéro spécial du sky
et co consacrée à l'aéronautique face à
la crise sanitaire et nous ferons ce
focus sur ce secteur chez safran le
groupe safran est présent sur trois
sites à saint-quentin-en-yvelines safran
site à plaisir s'affrontent avec à magny
les hameaux puis un second site à magny
les hameaux avec safran aircraft engines
nous commencerons cette émission ici
donc à safran et martin sheen dans le
cadre de la maintenance des moteurs
d'avion ici 700 collaborateurs
travaillent au quotidien pour réparer
les moteurs d'avion puis nous irons en
immersion sur le site de safran tech
spécialisée dans la recherche &
technologie ou des chercheurs planchent
pour développer l'avion qui sera moins
polluants c'est au programme de ce
numéro spécial du sky échos
[Musique]
le groupe safran a annoncé ses résultats
pour l'année 2000 21 après une année
2010 marquée par la crise sanitaire et
une chute de 36% du chiffre d'affaires
2021 c'est l'année de la reprise les
détails dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
il
bon
moi
est l'illustration parfaite de la
reprise d'activité pour le groupe safran
s'est notamment ici sur le site safran
aircraft engines de saint quentin en
yvelines vous voyez autour de moi tous
ces moteurs d'avion en maintenant c'est
pour en parler nous sommes avec le
directeur du site touba de courson
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors d'abord avant de parler de la
reprise parlons de la crise sanitaire
comment vous l'avez vécu ici à la crise
sanitaire a été très impactante on a des
c l'activité d'au moins 40% pendant les
deux années qui ont se sont passées
alors donc on a mis en place un accord
de transition d'activité avec les
représentants du personnel qui nous a
permis de mettre en place du chômage
partiel et puis de n'avoir aucun
licenciement pour pouvoir maintenir les
compétences en vue de la reprise là on
le voit il ya des moteurs sur les
chaînes de montage pendant la crise
c'est évident alors pendant la crise on
a quand même continué à travailler on
avait à peu près 55 moteur sur place
pendant l'année 2020 et 2021 et puis
l'un pour la reprise on a des
perspectives vraiment très intéressante
au moins 70 moteur on en parlera après
justement comment elle a commencé cette
reprise et à quel moment alors la
reprise elle a démarré déjà dès le début
du mois de décembre
les trafics aérien et repartit décembre
2021 2021 tout à fait on avait de plus
en plus de demandes de nombreuses
compagnies aériennes qui
étant donné qu'elles reprennent leurs
activités ont besoin de faire réviser
dans moteur finalement c'est un décalage
jusque là maintenant c'est après la
reprise des vols absolument absolument
oui
il ya un léger décalage entre les
reprises d'activité et puis les demandes
de révision du moteur tout à fait la
reprise est synonyme aussi de
recrutement safran aircraft and his
envisage de recruter 1400 personnes est
ici notamment ses 80 parce qu'ils sont
ouverts dans les 18 prochains mois c'est
ça tout à fait donc pour accompagner
cette reprise on a besoin absolument de
renforcer nos ressources on est en
recherche de mécanicien aéronautique de
contrôleur qualité d'ajusteur et nous
sommes très ouverts à de nombreux
recrutements et justement on va
découvrir tout de suite une offre
d'emploi dans cette séquence elles
recrutent
je suis charline cana garage je suis
chargé recrutement pour la société
safran aircraft and in pour le site de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à la recherche
d'environ dizaine de mécaniciens et
également des inspecteurs moteur
[Musique]
le mécanisme auteurs et les chargés de
démonter de moteurs et de dispatcher un
peu les modules et ensuite une fois que
c'est réparé et de remonter
le moteur dans son ensemble où le module
donc l'inspecteur c'est juste avant le
mécanisme moteur donc l'inspecteur il
fait donc une inspection générale du
moteur ou des modules donc c'est comme
un médecin généraliste qui regarde si le
produit va bien
[Musique]
vous êtes issu voilà d'une formation en
aéronautique que ce soit un bts ou bac
pro donc bien sûr c'est les profils
recherchés mais aujourd'hui voilà si
vous venez donc de l'automobile ou dans
notre domaine avec une expertise
mécanique vous êtes les bienvenus si
vous intéressé par le poste il suffit de
postuler sur le site de safran point com
et également nous suivre dans les
réseaux comme linkedin twitter instagram
[Musique]
et le sky est qu à safran aircraft
engine se poursuit avec thomas de
courson thomas de courson après avoir
fait un bilan de la crise et après avoir
parlé de la reprise d'activité parlant
des perspectives pour 2022 alors les
perspectives elles sont vraiment très
positive pour le site de saint quentin
en yvelines on a énormément de demandes
de la part de nombreuses compagnies
aériennes on est à peu près sur une
cible de 70 75 moteur pour l'année 2022
et puis on vise au moins 100 incendie
moteur pour l'année 2000 23 et sur la
stratégie à long terme ailleurs des
investissements ont parlé de ses 1400
recrutement pour le groupe safran
ailleurs kraft et jeans pour la filiale
safran est ratée jean c'est ce qu' il va
aussi des investissements nouvelles
machines des nouveaux moteurs alors on
est en train de négocier avec les
partenaires sociaux un accord qui vise à
modifier notre organisation du travail
et qui si il aboutit nous permettra donc
de renforcer fortement les
investissements sur le site au moins 10
millions d'euros et une centaine
d'embauchés supplémentaires eh bien
merci thomas de course ont repris je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur du
site safran aircraft engines saint
quentin en yvelines et justement on va
les rencontrer
marina writer est les mécaniciennes
aéronautique sur le site depuis sept ans
regardez
je m'appelle marine j'ai 31 ans je suis
monteur aux mfp depuis 7 ans j'ai fait
deux ans de formation ici en bac
professionnel
[Musique]
l'activité c'est de monter démonter des
des compresseurs haute pression
du triple sept
[Musique]
à partir du 1er confinement on a
commencé à voir beaucoup d'activité
partielle en gros on demande à nos
collègues de rester chez eux ils étaient
quand même payer mais on avait de moins
en moins de moteur sur le site et du
coup y avait pas du travail pour tout le
monde en plus c'était c'était un peu
long c'était c'est un moment où il n'y
avait pas grand monde dans l'atelier
nous on a l'habitude de voir pas mal de
monde parce qu'on est censé être 700 sur
le site et là c'était assez vide on
avait des périodes non travaillées pas
du tout des périodes où certaines
personnes travaillent et enfin c'était
pas du tout la même ambiance de travail
c'était assez stressant au quotidien et
puis les gens s'inquiétaient aussi pour
l'avenir du site comme
la reprise je pense que ça a rassuré pas
mal de mes collègues qui ont fini par
dire bon bah ça va on n'a plus à
s'inquiéter pour notre avenir
oui ça fait plaisir de reprendre à un
rythme stable l'activité partielle elle
a pris fin il ya un mois et demi deux
mois mon vrai donc ça a quand même duré
très longtemps avant qu'on reprenne un
vrai rythme
c'est un vrai plaisir c'est
le fait d'avoir passé toutes ces années
gt gt à la réunion il ya une grosse
crise de l'emploi là bas donc d'être
arrivé ici trouver du travail facilement
en plus un travail qui avait plutôt bien
rémunérés qui est derrière est agréable
quand même c'est vraiment un travail on
est content de venir
[Musique]
et
c
[Musique]
et me voilà dans la peau d'un apprenti
en mécanique aéronautique en compagnie
de mon instructeur d'un jour thierry
boissière bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
ont fait les formations en interne
pendant six à huit semaines les
formations qui vont râler sur dieu s est
ce de la formation technique et de la
formation sur le côté pratique ça c'est
un moteur de vivre c'est ça absolument
c'est les derniers venant de safran le
leap donc là c'est parti comme jean qui
est fabriqué avec la collaboration de
réunir activement concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on apprend comment ça s'apprend aussi
les bâtiments facile il fait suffit de
passer par des instructeurs comme moi
par exemple aujourd'hui ou comprends les
gens avec la documentation que nous
avons en face là bas et on prend un
outillage nos gars de travail ils ont
fait les opérations phase par phase et
on apprend en fait en pratiquant
absolument c'est le plus facile pour ce
type de machine parce que c'est de la
machine très lourde très lourde et très
complexe on va dire au niveau
technologie mission est alors tiré
qu'est ce que vous m'avez préparer
aujourd'hui eh bien nous allons faire le
montage d'un module sap est le menu 53
sur le corps du cfm ses produits par
dont il parle c'est parti c'est parti
il suffit de prendre le sillage d'un
stop et nicolas
[Musique]
avant c'est relativement lourd quand
même
sont essayés donc on montre là où il
vient de visser sesto place voilà donc
là je monte sur l'escabeau absolument je
vous en fais
et donc il suffit de visser de vie c'est
ça c'est quoi comme partie du moteur ça
c'est un gué du vêtement et ça permet de
quoi en fait de positionner ou alors on
va y aller tranquillement doucement
voilà je suffira voilà ça suffira celle
ci servira de guide pour monter
l'outillage pour centrer notre module
par rapport aux ventes est du corps on a
un parti basse pression qui est devant
la salle partie haute pression qui donne
l'énergie au moteur pour pouvoir faire
tourner la partie basse pression qui l'a
1 4 1 % de la puissance du moteur alors
après cet outil de guidage finalement la
deuxième étape c'est quoi eh bien
nicolas tu peux venir avec moi j'étais
d'accueillir va
cet outillage et le monter directement
sur le module d'accord donc là
finalement ça c'est la descente c'est ça
ça descend aussi moi qui m'en occupe
et on va directement le positionner sur
sur le pillage
et ça c'est quoi en fait c'est un
distributeur n'attend que ça redresse
les flux d'air chaud qui viennent de la
chambre de combustion donc va jeter
préparer nicolas davis et des écrous
d'accord c'est un peu comme un meccano
quand tu étais jeune il suffit de les
mettre à l'intérieur tout ça bouge un
petit jeu et appelons bien vissé
c'est vrai que ça rappelle la jeunesse
on serre la main faut serrer fort comme
en concert à la marmite pour celui-ci
voilà c'est pas évident il ya le
deuxième plus gros escrocs sur le court
on veut faire une petite on fait
toujours un tchèque pour voir si tout
rond a fait son travail correctement
finalement la sécurité fait partie
intégrante de la formation bien sûr il
faut aussi faut pas oublier le ss e
sécurité et santé et environnement aussi
qu'il peut à partie intégralement pour
le salarié et pour nos passagers et nos
clients aussi on sait que le dernier les
dernières visites en paix
[Musique]
voici donc après une fois qu'on a fait
le tchèque on peut leurrer la pièce
on fait un chèque visuels pour toutes
les pièces montées montée du module
complet d'accord oui parce que
effectivement on voit davis à
l'intérieur oui bien sûr donc il faut
s'assurer que tout soit conforme pour le
montage final et toutes ces
vérifications se font à partir du plan
qui a sur l'écran absolument
documentation qui est un réseau et qui a
en live bien sûr et la mise à jour se
fait au quotidien
d'accord donc c'est notre gamme de
travail et nos instructions de travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'invite à monter là haut sur nicolas
alors je monte voilà hélas falloir être
rigoureux comme toute phase de métier
c'est de pouvoir aligner le centrage de
l'outillage avec le dis que tu as mis en
premier
là ça devrait mieux
on a tous peur
fillon viendra se positionner
directement à sa base
et là on peut vérifier en même temps que
le jeu est bien maintenue en plus de
pièces
et via un bravo nicolas tu es monté tout
premier module sur le leap merci thierry
pour ses explications je rappelle que
vous êtes instructeur pour safran
aircraft engines 2 saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
et après avoir vu la reprise d'activité
dans le cadre de la maintenance des
moteurs d'avion tournons nous vers
l'avenir avec le programme de l'avion
vers et les sujets environnementaux
direction safran tech
nous avons rejoint le site safran paris
saclay le coeur stratégique de la
recherche et technologie du groupe i 6
500 chercheurs de safran tech travail
sur les futures innovations de
l'équipementier aéronautique des
matériaux de demain aux nouvelles
méthodes en passant par les énergies bas
carbone
[Musique]
c'est l'un des points stratégiques pour
le groupe safran basculer vers l'avion
vert pour cela safran va investir 4
milliards d'euros entre 2021 et 2025
trois quarts de sa terme à this man va
être accordée à la décarbonation de
l'avion pour en parler nous sommes avec
le directeur de s'affronter que vincent
garnier bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors s'affrontaient qu'est ce que c'est
alors ça frontex et le centre de
recherche mutualisé du groupe safran
nous travaillons au sein du centre de
recherche sur un certain nombre de
thématiques transverses à l'ensemble des
sociétés du groupe safran et l'objectif
est de travailler sur les nouvelles
technologies qui vont précisément être
intégré dans l'avion vers à l'horizon de
2035 le centre de recherche là dedans
est un élément clé qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver un avion vers qu'est-ce que
safran va pouvoir y apporter d'abord un
moteur beaucoup plus performants que les
moteurs même ceux qui viennent d'entrer
en service ou savez peut-être safran a
fait rentrer en service récemment un
nouveau moteur qui fait un gain de
carburant de 15% par rapport aux avions
qui volent en majorité dans la flotte
actuelle et nous prévoyons d'ici 2035 de
faire entrer en service un nouveau type
de moteur et ce nouveau type de moteur
nous préparons de nous commençons de
préparer dès aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet
d'un programme de recherche et
technologie que nous avons annoncés ici
même à magny les hameaux il ya un peu
plus d'un an maintenant le directeur
général du groupe l'a fait lui-même pour
vous dire l'importance que ce programme
revêt pour le groupe et donc c'est le
premier élément vraiment de l'avion vers
vue de sa france et ce moteur qui va
faire bénéficier l'avion qu'il portera
de 20 % de gain de consommation
supplémentaire par rapport à la
référence déjà extrêmement performante
qui est le moteur leap on va travailler
également dans l'avion vers sur le fait
d'aller j'ai tous les équipements et là
c'est vraiment des thématiques de type
matériaux beaucoup plus performant
beaucoup plus robuste beaucoup plus
léger qui vont permettre à l'ensemble
des équipements du groupe d'être ré
redimensionner vraiment réexaminée dans
leur au plus profond d'eux-mêmes pour
pouvoir faire alléger l'avion qui va les
porter finalement y'a pas que le facteur
énergie parce que quand on entend parler
d'environnement parle souvent d'énergies
renouvelables finalement vous vous ne
semblez pas uniquement le facteur
énergie alors on fait tout ce qu'on va
faire va
aller dans le sens d'améliorer
l'efficacité vraiment du système de
transport aérien j'ai parlé du moteur
j'ai parlé de l'allègement il faut
savoir qu'un autre pilier de la
décarbonation du transport aérien
puisque le transport aérien vise vous le
savez d'être neutre en carbone à
l'horizon 2050 l'autre pilier de cette
transformation c'est la mise à
disposition de carburant à d'aviation
durable et donc le nous dans le cadre de
l'avion vers nous travaillons ce que
toutes les technologies que nous
proposons puisse être compatible avec
ces carburants durables nous en parler
du carburant justement mais vous êtes
engagé aussi dans le verdissement du
carburant à travers le développement du
bio carburant et vous avez passé un
partenariat avec total énergie
qu'est ce que vous faites chez safran
tech par rapport aux biocarburants alors
on étudie dans le biocarburant fait
qu'elle pourra être ses meilleures
propriétés ça ça ça paraît peut-être un
peu étrange mais aujourd'hui les
carburants qui sont utilisés dans
l'aéronautique sont sont le kérosène qui
est un dérivé bien sûr du pétrole tout à
fait classique c'est un très très bon
carburant sens que il est parfaitement
stable il peut être utilisé dans plein
de conditions les plus extrêmes c'est un
vraiment à carburant un peu rêvé pour
l'aéronautique et on cherche à
reproduire ses excellentes
caractéristiques avec du carburant qu'on
appelle de synthèse des issues des bio
de la biomasse par exemple et donc on se
demande si en utilisant dès le départ
une source comme la biomasse on ne peut
pas construire un carburant encore
meilleur que le kérosène d'un carburant
qui émettra encore moins de dérivés
deux types particules par exemple un
carburant qui permettra de mieux
maîtriser les émissions d'oxydés d'azoté
voilà et donc ça fait partie des
recherches que nous menons effectivement
avec total dans le cadre de ce
partenariat et dans le cadre également
de gros projets de recherche qui sont ce
qu'ils sont soutenus par le par la dg
assez pour comprendre quels sont les
meilleurs ingrédients d'un carburants
durables pour l'aéronautique à l'horizon
des prochaines années puisque l'ambition
de l'ensemble de l'industrie c'est bien
de faire monter ses carburants en volume
et petit à petit de complètement
remplacer les carburants d'origine
fossile par ces carburants durables et
dans toutes ces erreurs charge vous êtes
soutenus par l'état puisque l'avion vers
c'est un des programmes du plan france
relance 1 25 milliard d'euros sur trois
ans investi par l'état qu'est ce que
vous avez fait le parti vous avez
bénéficié vous avez bénéficié de combien
chez safran alors le plan de relance il
est venu déjà à point nommé on a
mentionné cette fameuse crise sanitaire
tout à l'heure vraiment il nous a permis
de rebondir j'ai utilisé le terme c'est
un des ingrédients qui nous a permis de
rebondir très fortement et au total il
se développe sur
2020 2024 on a commencé à signer des
contrats de subvention avec l'état en
2020 et on va finir on va signer les
derniers contrats ici en 2022 début 2022
pour une activité qui va se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2024 pour sa france et
représente sans doute une centaine de
projets et une subvention de l'ordre de
400 440 millions d'euros donc vraiment
une subvention très substantiels dont
que nous utilisons comme un effet levier
puisque safran au fur et à mesure que
l'industrie ont rebondi que notre
activité repart que notre profitabilité
s'améliore a décidé d'investir ses
propres ressources pour accompagner bien
sûr ce plan de relance pour bénéficier
de l'effet multiplicateur et c'est ce
qui donne en finale ce fameux 4
milliards que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure sur cinq ans pour aller
développer les technologies comme le
motoriste comme les allègements
l'électrification des activités qui sont
présentes d'ici six à magny les hameaux
mais mise à part la décarbonation de
l'avion il y à d'autres sujets aussi je
crois savoir qu on pourrait peut-être
voir des systèmes autonomes dans les
aéronefs au sol pour bien rassuré tout
le monde sait bien au sol à
l'utilisation des aéronefs au sol c'est
une partie importante de la dette bien
sûr de leur fiabilité de l'au delà de
l'efficacité du système on évoquait sa
tout à l'heure le transport aérien est
une machine extrêmement efficace et elle
se renforce tous les jours cette
efficacité donc une idée qu'on a eu pour
combiner le
l'efficacité énergétique et l'efficacité
tout simplement l'organisation c'est
d'électrifier les avions au sol c'est à
dire vous parliez tout à l'heure de à
quel moment de la mission un avion
peut-il est électrifiée bien son taxing
comme on dit au sol c'est un c'est une
phase très importante qui consomment
plusieurs pourcents d'ailleurs de
l'énergie qui utilisent un avion dans
son dans sa mission faut le savoir donc
une des choses qu'on fait c'est
travailler sur ce taxiing électrique une
autre chose qu'on fait c'est essayer
d'optimiser la façon dont l'avion et est
menée dans ces phases là et donc on
s'est dit au fond pourquoi ne pas
appliquer pour cette phase de thaksin
une démarche de type autonomie tel qu'on
peut le voir aujourd'hui sur des
véhicules terrestres parce que les
équipages ont besoin d aide sur cette
phase là qui sont souvent compliquées il
faut aller s'insérer dans un mine de
rien dans un trafic qui peut être assez
serré dans un aéroport et donc on s'est
dit avec les équipements du groupe
safran ce qu on est ce qu'on essaie ici
dans un laboratoire effectivement
d'autonomie que nous partageons avec
valéo estelle antilles c'est une très
belle démarche de recherche
collaborative que nous avons menées ici
que nous menons toujours on met au point
des systèmes autonomes des capteurs des
algorithmes et puis on teste tout ça
dans des véhicules terrestres qu'on fait
tourner autour du site ici on a
digitalisées l'ensemble de saint quentin
en yvelines pour faire circuler des
véhicules et on applique ça dans le
domaine aéronautique a une idée de faire
du thaksin autonome et puis nous
également safran dans le domaine
militaire puisqu'on avait également une
activité de défense des équipements de
défense terrestre merci vincent garnier
merci je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de safran tech
s
c'est la fin de ce sky échos spéciale
consacrée à l'aéronautique merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir cette
émission à ripley sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]